so good enough fighting stats we'll
review a couple uh okay reflective
reactions
okay okay all right okay that's not
reviewing
well that's kicking me and stopping my
heart
that said i think i took it like a man
yeah i think i'm ready to go
arm you're pretty warm all right okay
right now let's just stand here
settle down a little bit what's that
settle down you don't kick a man four
times and then tell him to settle down
okay we're gonna do one more kick i'm
gonna do a round uh hook kick to your
head
yeah what do i do for now let's just see
your basic reaction we'll take it from
there and
it's a fake reaction you're not really
gonna hit me in the face not yet okay so
just stay loose let's try it on three
two one
boom okay like that did that look like
anything um it was a little tight
i think we need to loosen up like loosen
up your shoulders here this is the line
you use on all guys
like that so it's more okay like this
all right good okay that did nothing but
all right
you just need to loosen up a bit but now
let's let's try this now that you have
that
okay this is a nice little trick that we
do for uh slow motion close-ups
okay so assuming we're playing for this
camera right there
this camera right here okay your frame
is really tight so you can't go in and
out of frame
right all i'm going to do is i'm going
to do this because for your own safety
because i don't want to kick you for
real in the face
right i'm going to put this in my hand
it's a nice little hollywood trick yeah
and i'll just slap you as hard as i can
with the shoe
and then you go around and then there
you are there's your tape
now okay why isn't this like a fake shoe
made of soft marshmallow why is this sir
this is a hard shoe i asked for a soft
shoe this is what i got oh
who's helping me out okay so you're
gonna hit me there and i'm gonna go that
way right but let's do something more
yes so let's give you some blood um this
is movie blood
movie blood so some people make it out
of syrup some people out of yogurt i'm
not sure what that is
okay uh and we could actually add some
teeth to the mix
oh this is going to be tea so what you
want me to do is get hit
in the head turn this way and have all
that stuff come out of my face just make
sure you project out and spit don't let
it dribble
it has a different effect if it dribbles
yeah i know what would happen why do you
think i'd get hit and go like okay
no i know what to do okay
[Music]
make sure you don't swallow
[Applause]
good warning that's awesome okay so
we'll go on three two one
ready play to that camera three
two one
could we see that again on slow motion
let's see kind of what that looked like
i'm just curious if that looks like
kabam
[Applause]
let's just what why did we stay on it
for 10 minutes after i got hit
it became this weird silent french film
that wasn't bad okay what's next this is
a blood knife it's really simple it's
basically a rubber tube or condom on
you think about it any real knife is a
blood knife potentially
so the blood is inside here and all i
have to do is blood is inside show us
that
this tube right here okay tube right
there filled with blood all right right
along the side of the handle demonstrate
on me
right here and basically if you run it
along skin or i could do it on your hand
or i could do it on your neck whatever
well let's do this i can give it a
squeeze
and then
wow that's pretty cool and that would
work anywhere
yeah you could do it on your face if
you'd like on your neck
oh we need to reload it
[Applause]
this just made me look like an idiot i
went ah
and then there was nothing there okay
which shot is that
we're asking well now we're gonna do the
famous shot of uh someone's there's like
a
horrible butchery going on right here
and i'm getting blood yeah it's
basically your reaction where you're
looking at me and something's happening
to me or i'm attacking you
and basically i'm just splattering you
with blood ah
yeah okay that's
it all right that exact shitty that was
what
what was that you need to see more blood
no
why did you do that that they're
hollywood secrets
okay yeah okay let's take it i always
wondered how that was done